Why we Throw Coins into Fountains
People have been throwing coins into fountains
seemingly as long as there have been coins
and fountains.
The tradition all started with water.
While many people in the developed world today
have clean, drinkable water readily available
from their kitchen taps, this was not always
the case.
Potable drinking holes in many regions weren’t
the easiest things to find.
Thus, where clean water was available, many
early European tribes believed that such areas
were a gift from the gods.
The idea that drinkable water was sent from
the heavens remained even as wells and fountains
were built.
Often, a small statue of a god could be found
next to early wells and fountains, turning
them into a type of shrine.
As you probably already know, presenting gifts
to gods is an ancient practice that was usually
meant to appease angry gods, or to act as
a payment for a request or prayer.
In the case of fountains and wells, people
would toss in a coin while sending up a prayer—an
early version of making a wish.
One rather prolific well can be found in Northumberland,
England, and was used to pray to the Celtic
goddess of wells and springs, Coventina.
16,000 coins from different eras of the Roman
Empire were found there.
Interestingly, most of the coins found in
the Coventina Fountain were low denominations,
much like today where people are usually more
willing to part with a 5 or 10 cent coin rather
than a full dollar, euro, or pound.
Of course, it wasn’t always coins.
The Well of Pen Rhys in Oxford, England called
for pieces of clothing to be tossed in.
In this case, it was thought that the water
had healing powers and that the clothing carried
disease, so by tossing a button, pin, or piece
of fabric into the well, you would be healed.
The belief in the healing powers of the Well
of Pen Rhys remained popular well into the
18th century.
These days, believing in gods watching over
the wells or the thought that water has healing
powers has largely lost favour, but people
still practice this ancient tradition, in
modern times usually making a wish.
Probably one of the most famous examples of
a wishing fountain is the Trevi Fountain in
Rome.
The Trevi Fountain was built as the ending
point of a 21 kilometre long aqueduct called
Virgo, named for the goddess who would guide
soldiers to water when they were thirsty and
tired.
Originally, tossing a coin in or taking a
drink from the fountain was supposed to ensure
good health.
Eventually, the tradition evolved to what
we know today: if you toss a coin over your
shoulder into the fountain, you will one day
return to Rome.
This idea was popularized in the 1954 film
Three Coins in the Fountain, which also suggested
that if you throw two coins in, you’ll fall
in love with a Roman, and if you throw three
coins in, you’ll marry him or her.
Since the movie, this practice has become
so popular with tourists that it’s estimated
that around €3,000 in coins are thrown in
the fountain every day.
Obviously, all of those coins can’t just
sit in the fountain forever.
The Trevi Fountain shuts down for one hour
every day and the coins are swept out by the
Roman Catholic charity Caritas, which pays
for food for the poor as well as Aids shelters.
The coins have to be cleaned, sorted into
different denominations, and sent off
to the bank.